مرحبا بكم نزيل العابدين توفيق سنتابع معا
ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي بايجاد ضمن
ابرز الاحداث
اردوغان رئيسا لتركيا تعليقهم مباحثات جدا
بشان السودان واشبيليه بطلا للدوري
الاوروبي لدينا اخبار اخرى سنتابعها معا
نبدا نشرتنا بفوز الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان بولايه رئاسيه ثالثه واخيرا
الحالي معلنا بدايه مئويه تركيا وذلك بعد
حصوله في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
على اكثر من 52% من الاصوات وفي سياق متصل
نقلت وكاله رويترز عن باسورينا رفيع
المستوى ان التشكيله الوزاريه الجديده من
شبه المؤكد ان تضم رئيس المخابرات هاكان
فيدان والمتحدث باسم الرياسه ابراهيم قالن
والمسؤوله الاقتصاديه السابق محمد شمشك
منصات التواصل شاهد التفاعلات واسعه رافقت
فوز اردوغان برئاسه تركيا نرصد لكم بعضا
من هذه التفاعلات سيد ابو يوسف يقول
اردوغان رئيسا لتركيا كل ما كان يملكه
كمارك هو مشروع ترحيل اللاجئين وفي احد
خطاباته عندما سمع صوت الاذان صمت احتراما
للاذان وقام برسم القلب بيديه وده اكبر
حزب علماني في تركيا
تخالف او قد تختلف مع اردوغان ولكن يكفيه
انه رفع الحظر عن الحجاب وانه وقف الى
جانب اللاجئين عبد الخالق عبد الله يقول
اردوغان رئيسا لتركيا حتى سنه 2018
فاز بفارق اربع نقاط فقط فاكثر من سبعه
واربعين بالمئه من الشعب التركي لم يصوت
له ولا يرغب به رئيسا الان الى السوداني
اعلنت واشنطن والرياض تعليقه مباحثات
الجده بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع قال بيان للسفاره الامريكيه في
الخرطوم عند القرار جاء نتيجه الانتهاكات
الجسيمه المتكرره لوقف اطلاق النار بين
اطراف القتال مضيفا ان الطرفين ارتكبان
انتهاكات خطيره اثرت بشكل مباشر على جهود
المساعدات الانسانيه وشملت احتلال منازل
مدنيه وشركات خاصه ومباني العامه
ومستشفيات وشمل ايضا ضربات جويه ومدفعيه
لكن لماذا يستمر فشل الهدى هذا ما سنسال
عنه مراسل الجزيره اسامه سيدي احمد مرحبا
اسامه
كلما اتفق الاطراف على اجراء هدنه تحدث
خروقات لماذا
السبب زين ربما يعود لاصرار كل طرف على
مواصله القتال في ارض المعركه يعول كل من
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه للحسم
العسكري من اجل كسب نقاط على المستوى
الميداني ربما يحدث ذلك سعيا وراء تحسين
مواقفهما التفاوضيه في مدينه جده رقم
اعلان الوساطه تعليق المفاوضات
ورغمه
تبادل الطرفين للاتهامات بخرق الهدنه
الحاليه وايضا الهدن السابقه لكن ربما
يعود الطرفان لاحقا الى طاوله المفاوضات
من جديد الجيش السوداني طبعا يطالب بخروج
قوات الدعم السريع من المستشفيات والمرافق
الخدميه وعدم الاحتماء بالاحياء وعدم
اتخاذ المواطنين دروعا بشريه بينما يتهم
الدعم السريع الجيش السوداني باستمرار
القصف الجوي ومهاجمه
واقعه مركزه تمركز قواته في مناطق متفرقه
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم شكرا اسامه
نذهب الى كوسو والتي تعيش احداثا ساخنه هي
الاخرى وذلك بعد اشتباكات شماليه البلاد
بين الشرطه الكوسفيه وقوات حلف الشمال
الاطلسي من جانب ومتظاهرين الصرب من
الجانب الاخر حاولوا اقتحام مبنى حكومي
احتجاجا على تنصيب رؤساء بلديات البان في
المناطق التي يشكل الصرب غالبيه سكانها
رئيسه كوسوفو دعت صربيا الى وقف دعمها لمن
وصفتهم بالعصابات الاجراميه اذا ارادت
سلاما حقيقيا كما قرر النيتو نشر قوات
اضافيه فهل يا ترى تشهد اوروبا حربا ثانيه
يمكنكم متابعه المزيد عن هذا النزاع واصله
في التقرير اسفل التعليقات الان الى
الولايات المتحده وتطورات ازمه الدين
الرئيس الامريكي تعهد بالتصديق على مشروع
القانون المسؤوليه الماليه المتعلق بسقف
الدين العام والذي يجنب الحكومه الامريكيه
التخلف عن سداد ديونها بعدما صدق عليه
الكونجرس بمجلسه تم ابرام صفقه حد الدين
بين البيت الابيض والحزب الجمهوري تتويجا
من المفاوضات والمحادثات التي شهدت شدا
وجذبا ورد بين المعسكرين نسال الدكتور
خليل العدالي والصدر العلوم السياسيه عن
تفاصيل هذا الاتفاق دكتور خليل اهلا بك ما
هي نقطه الالتقاء التي تم التوصل اليها
بين الجانبين
نعم بعد مفاضاته استمر ما بين البيت
الابيض والكمريكي اتفق الطرفين مؤخرا على
رفع سقف الدين واللي بيعطي الحكومه
الامريكيه فرصه وامكانيه انها تدفع رواتب
موظفيها وانها ايضا تدفع فواترها لهذا
الاتفاق ينص على حاجتين اساسيتين الحاجه
الاولى هي ان يتم رفع سقف الدين كي يصل
الى 31 تريليون ونصف دولار حتى يناير من
عام 20 25 فبنتكلم على سنه ونص من دلوقتي
الحاجه التانيه في مقابل ذلك هو تخفيض
وتقليل الانفاق الحكومي على بعض المشاريع
وهذا يعتبر احد من طلب الرئيسيه
للجمهوريين كيوافقوا على هذا الاتفاق هذا
الاتفاق بيجنب امريكا والعالم الدخول في
ازمه ماليه واقتصاديه غير مسبوقه
شكرا دكتور خليل ونخت مناشرتنا بالاخبار
الرياضيه الابرز هذا الاسبوع حيث توج
اشبيليه الاسباني بطلا للدوري الاوروبي
للمره السابعه في تاريخه بفوزه على روما
الايطالي بركلات الترجيح بعد نهايه الوقت
الاصلي للقاء بهدف لكل منهما هذه المباراه
طبعا شهدت تالقا لافته للحارس المغربي
ياسين بونو الذي حصل على جائزه رجل
المباراه في اخبارنا الاخرى ايضا يستمر
الترقب والجدل حول انتقال قائد المنتخب
الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي والنجم الفرنسي
كريم بنزيما الى الدوري السعودي بعد انباء
متضاربه حول قرار النجبين انتم ايضا
شاركونا ارائكم هل تتوقعون انتقالهما
لينافسا رونالدو في الدوري السعودي وصلنا
لنهايه هذه النشره نلتقي بكم باذن الله في
ايجاز اخر الاسبوع المقبل في امان الله
[موسيقى]